das ist unser hotel
es sieht toll aus
ja ich freue mich schon auf unseren
aufenthalt
wir werden uns schön entspannen können
das uns reingehen
an der rezeption machen wir den check-in
danach können wir in unser zimmer gehen
das hört sich gut an
[Musik]
guten tag
wir haben eine verwirrung
wir haben eine reservierung
name ist pascal
wärme ist pascal
guten tag und herzlich willkommen
ich schaue kurz im system nach
genau
sie bleiben zwei nächte bei uns
ist das richtig
ja das ist richtig
sehr gut
ich sehe dass sie bei
mit der karte bezahlt haben
ich sehe dass sie bereits mit der karte
bezahlt haben
somit können sie gleich ins zimmer gehen
genau das ist richtig
hier haben sie ihre schlüssel
sie sind im zimmer nummer 3 102
ich wünsche ihnen
schönen aufenthalt
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
aufenthalt
vielen dank
ich bin müde von der reise
ich freue mich auf mein bett
hoffentlich ist es bequem
ja ich bin auch müde
lasst uns doch 30 minuten erholen
danach können wir ins fitness zentrum
gehen
ich muss heute noch sport machen
ja das hört sich gut an
dort nach einer reise ist eine
großartige idee
nach dem sport möchte ich aber zum pool
gehen
bist du einverstanden
bist du einfach anderen
ja genau das wollte ich dir auch
vorschlagen
wow das zimmer sieht wunderschön aus
[Musik]
hier werde ich super schlafen können
ja es ist modern und groß
es gefällt mir sehr
ich möchte mich jetzt hinlegen
danach können wir ins fitness zentrum
gehen
genau
lasst uns kurz schlafen
danach können wir sport machen
okay das können wir machen
30 minuten später
wow das hat aber gut getan
ich fühle mich jetzt viel fitter
du auch
ja mir geht es viel besser
ich könnte jetzt aber noch länger
schlafen
true faulpelz
drew faulpelz
c dich um jetzt gehen wir sport machen
zieh dich um jetzt gehen wir sport
machen
ja ja ist schon gut
ich bin in fünf minuten bereit
ich ziehe mich jetzt um
super
super ich ziehe mich auch um
ich ziehe mich auch um
ich bin müde
ich werde heute nur 30 minuten
trainieren
das reicht mir
da es reicht mir
ja das reicht mir auch
ich möchte nur auf dem laufband rennen
[Musik]
danach mache ich noch einige übungen
genau so habe ich mir das auch
vorgestellt
15 minuten später
ach ich bin kaputt
ja ich bin kaputt
ich kann nicht mehr
ich höre auf für heute
morgen komme ich wieder
ich bin auch fix und fertig
vor dem training zu schlafen war keine
gute idee
dem training zu schlafen war keine gute
idee
egal lasst uns duschen gehen
danach gehen wir zum pool
wow
der pool ist ja riesig
das wird toll
ja und die aussicht ist atemberaubend
schau dir mal die stadt an
viermal die stadt an
ich bin so glücklich hier zu sein
ja ich auch
ich gehe jetzt ins wasser
dort kann ich mich entspannen
das hört sich gut an
ich komme auch ins wasser
danach will ich auf dem liegestuhl
sonnen baden
das wasser ist aber frisch
ich muss wieder raus
ich will mich in der sonne aufwärmen
du bist ein weichei
das wasser ist toll
ich bleibe noch ein bisschen
einige stunden später
ich habe lust auf cocktails
dieser urlaub ist toll
und diese aussicht bei nacht
unbezahlbar
freut mich zu sehen dass es dir gefällt
es freut mich zu sehen dass es dir
gefällt
es ist wirklich großartig hier
ich möchte eine margarita trinken
da bin ich dabei
[Musik]
ich möchte auch eine margarita trinken
guten abend
das darf es für sie sein
bitte zwei margarita
vielen dank
zwei margaritas kommt sofort
das ist eine tolle art um den abend
ausklingen zu lassen
cocktails in einer rooftop bar
cocktails einer rooftop bar
das sollten wir häufiger machen
ich bin einverstanden
dafür müssen wir nicht in den urlaub
gehen
wir können auch zu hause das leben
genießen
hier haben sie ihre margaritas
vielen dank
ich bin schon
ja
ich bin schon mühe ja
lasst uns die margaritas trinken
[Musik]
danach gehen wir schlafen
morgen schauen wir uns berlin an
[Musik]
das hört sich perfekt an
morgen sind wir wieder fit und munter
abonniere den kanal der halo deutsch
schule
aktiviere das kleine glöckchen
gib uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben
klicke auf diese playlist um weitere
videos zu sehen